>>Female Presenter: I'm very excited to welcome
Nancy Schulman and Ellen Birnbaum to Google
today.
Nancy and Ellen met about 30 years ago.
They were neighbors in a New York apartment
and happened to be pregnant expecting boys.
Nancy, her first.
Ellen, her second.
And were due within a month of each other.
Needless to say, this chance meeting led to
a very long friendship.
They not only became life-long friends, their
children grew up together.
Their boys are still very close friends.
Coincidentally, they also were both working
in Early Education when they met.
A few years into their friendship, they soon
found themselves working side by side at one
of the most admired nursery schools in the
country--the 92nd Street Y--where they worked
together for about 20 years building the school
and supporting families during the very special
preschool years.
Today, Ellen is the director of the 92nd Street
Y and Nancy has recently joined the Avenues,
the World School, to head their early education
program, which is opening next September.
I'm sure 30 years ago, neither one of them
thought that they would end up writing a book
giving parents like themselves wisdom and
sharing their insights as they raised their
children.
If you have not read their book, "Practical
Wisdom for Parents," I highly encourage you
to check it out.
We're selling copies in the back.
Drawing from their 50 plus years of early
education experience, they cover topics in
the book like selecting the right preschool
for your child and family, discipline, potty
training.
The book talks about play and activities that
are supportive and encouraging child's early
development.
They even address topics like talking to your
child about moving, death, divorce, and sex--something
I really didn't think would end up in a book
about preschool years.
So, I'd like to just welcome Nancy and Ellen
to share their insights on the preschool years.
Throughout their talk, please feel free to
ask questions, share your insights, and we'll
have questions in the end as well.
So, thanks for being here.
>>Nancy Schulman: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
[applause]
Thank you, Faith, for inviting us.
We're very excited to be here.
This is our first time at Google.
So, we're excited.
But the most exciting part is to see--.
I can't believe how many fathers are here.
It's really cool.
I mean, mothers we always see.
But dads, this is really cool.
I'm Nancy.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: And I'm Ellen.
I think it's very clear to both of us, since
we've been doing this, the role of fathers
has changed dramatically in the last 15 years.
And there is so much more hands-on parenting
from dads.
And we've seen a shift in the nursery school.
Fathers always came to parent conferences,
but when Nancy and I started having parent
conversations, we started to see increasing
numbers of dads over the years.
And we're so happy to see that because it's
the consistent messages that go from both
parents to children that are so important.
>>Nancy Schulman: So, we really think that
the preschool years--.
And we're talking about two-year olds through
five-year olds-- is the most important time
in the life of a family and in the life of
parents.
This is an amazing period of time and it's
the time that's very exhausting and overwhelming
as new parents are moving into this phase,
but it is by far the time when parents have
the most influence on the life of children.
You're there.
You're spending a lot of time with your children,
too.
And you're really laying the foundations for
who you're gonna be as a parent at this time.
You define what's important to you, what's
important to your family, what the rules are
in your home, thinking about all of those.
How to create children who are decent and
good and compassionate and cooperative and
respectful.
All of those things really happen during these
preschool years.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: And the most challenging
part of being a parent of a preschooler is
the transition from the infant/toddler parent
to the preschooler parent.
And you can see we have an infant on the floor
and you have to keep your eye on them all
the time because there's no end of trouble
that they're gonna get into because they have
no idea about limits and boundaries.
And as you transition into the parent of a
preschooler, you need to take a little bit
of a step back so that you can support their
independence from you because that's your
goal in life.
It's to care for them so that there can be
a person in the world without you.
>>Nancy Schulman: So, the first thing that
really starts to happen, and if you have two-year
olds, you probably heard, "I want to do it
myself."
That's the first thing that they start to
say when they have this growing independence.
And one of the greatest things that parents
can do for children is to really allow them
the time and the ability to do things for
themselves.
It's the thing, probably more than any other
thing, that helps build a feeling of confidence
in children.
When they feel competent that they can handle
their own needs, do the things that they need
to do for themselves, you see this incredible
puffed out feeling of competency and confidence
that comes from just doing basic things for
themselves.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: So, in an early childhood
classroom, children are taught this wonderful
Maria Montessori coat flip.
Have you ever seen a child--?
You put the coat in front of your toes, backwards,
with the collars facing you.
And the child digs their hands in and then
they flip the coat over their heads.
And you see this incredible "Aha, I did it"
moment.
And that's the beginning.
But children also in classrooms will put that
coat on their hook each day.
They will come to the table and eat and sit
in a chair and have a conversation in there
and pour their own water.
They'll throw their things away in the garbage.
They're expected to clean up the classroom
materials.
So, all of those things fostering this great
sense of pride and independence.
>>Nancy Schulman: One day in the nursery school,
we saw parents coming in and there was a father
who was bringing their two and a half-year
old daughter to the classroom.
And I was just watching from afar and she
did this thing that was so funny.
She just took her coat and let it drop behind
her very dramatically in that way.
And I just watched to see what he would do.
And he did what most of us would do-- the
expedient thing.
He picked it up and he put it on her hook
for her.
And later on, we were telling this story to
a group of parents and a mother looked and
said, "Oh, that was my daughter for sure,
and my husband for sure."
And we said, "Yeah, we weren't gonna tell,
but yeah.
It was."
Because it's those little moments of thinking
about what to do and how to support a child
that means you have to raise the bar a little
bit at each stage--every few months as they
get greater and greater capability of doing
things, to have the expectations grow at the
same time their skills are growing in that
way.
So, that father in that moment, because he
was probably in a hurry to get to work or
doing whatever he was doing, picked up the
coat and did that.
But as soon as he left, when the teachers
came out, they were gonna expect this child
to do that for themselves.
So, it's always a confusing message.
So, parents need to keep pace with children
as their development happens.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: So, right now there seems
to be an emphasis from parents and from the
culture for children to assume skill sets
that they don't really need.
I mean, a child doesn't really need to learn
to play tennis when they're three, or join
a soccer league when they're two and a half.
But they do need to be able to do all these
other things.
One day, we have an after school program at
the nursery school and one of the four-year
olds was taking a tennis lesson up on the
racket ball courts on the top of the Y.
But he had left his backpack on the sixth
floor where the nursery school is.
So, I went up with it and his caregiver was
there and she was spoon-feeding yogurt to
him.
Tennis lesson, couldn't feed himself.
It was a little confusing to me, so I went
downstairs and I called his mom.
And I said, "I thought you should know that
your caregiver was feeding him and I was a
little confused."
'Cause he was able to play tennis.
He should be able to feed himself.
"Oh, I'm gonna talk to her.
I told her not to do it anymore."
And of course, the next day, the caregiver
came up the elevator and threw her arms around
me and hugged me and she said, "I told her
I shouldn't be doing that anymore."
So, she knew clearly that the bar should be
the same for all of that.
If you're expecting your child to be able
to do that kind of thing, they should go to
the bathroom on their own and wipe themselves
and be able to do the basic stuff.
>>Nancy Schulman: It's interesting because
when you think about what children need from
parents at this age, all those things, it
can't be done with small bursts of high-quality
interaction.
I think the idea of quality time was a really
bad thing because the definition of quality
time means there can be no negative interaction
if we want it to be high-quality.
So, small bursts of high-quality time with
children, or large bursts of low-quality time
with children are not gonna--.
They need both from parents.
They need to be able to spend time doing fun,
focused activities together, playing together
and doing those kinds of things.
And they also need to get ready for the bath
and to have a conflict over who's gonna eat
your peas.
And all of those kinds of things are what
children need from parents.
It can't be just one way or the other way.
They need to know.
They need to know when you disapprove of them.
They need to know when those things are happening
and they only get it when it comes from the
parent directly.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: Nancy was talking about
having the courage of your convictions.
If you think what they're doing-- whoever
is telling you right or wrong--isn't right,
you need to be able to stand up to them and
for them.
Wendy Mogel, who wrote this wonderful book
called "Blessing of the Skinned Knee," talks
about assuming a mantle of authority with
your children.
You need to be in charge.
You're all in business.
You have a certain authority in the workplace.
Children need that from you as well.
>>Nancy Schulman: My daughter used to say
to me when I perfected the look--.
You know the look, the disapproving look?
Every parent should have one of them.
And she used to look at me when she was about
three-- 'cause I had to do it a lot with her--
she used to say, "Stop yelling at me."
I never said a word.
And I thought, "Good.
She gets it.
She knows."
They need to know your approval and they need
to know your disapproval.
It's how they take on their own sort of moral
development in that way, too.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: When Nancy and I first got
the opportunity to write the book, we were
struggling with what should come first.
Should we talk about home or should we talk
about school?
School was the thing we were most comfortable
with.
And then we thought about the children who
were so happy at school who were really successful
at being at school.
And we said, "If parents understood the expectations
of what we were doing here and they could
mirror it some way at home, we could have
this wonderful consistency which works so
well with children."
>>Nancy Schulman: So, the thing that works
so well with children in school that's easily
translatable to home is certainly consistent
expectations.
When you're managing a group of 16 children,
you have to have consistent expectations every
day.
When you're a parent at home where there's
two parents or a caregiver and two parents,
or one parent and a grandparent-- whatever
your dynamic is at home--the consistency of
expectation is essential.
And if that consistency can match the consistency
of what teachers expect at school, you see
children coming to school with a level of
comfort and confidence about "I get this.
I know what they're expecting of me.
It's similar at home.
I'm asked to put my toys away at home.
So when they ask me to put my toys away here,
it's not an unfamiliar concept."
We have a movement class where children have
to take their shoes and socks off.
Well, taking your shoes and socks off is very
easy for a three-year old and a four-year
old.
Putting them on--another story.
It's a little more difficult.
So we always tell parents and we laugh at
class because at the end, you can always tell
children who have never had the expectation
of doing that for them.
They sit at the end of the movement class
with their feet out like this.
It never occurs to them to attempt this.
And it's hard to put socks on.
That's not an easy skill.
But you need some time and you need to break
it down.
And you need to support it as they're doing
it.
I'll do a little.
You do the rest.
And give them that time.
But it takes time to do all that, too.
And it's not easy.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: Predictable routines.
Children are creatures of habit.
They love the same routines.
Start, first we're gonna do this and then
we're gonna do that and then we're gonna do
that.
And that's how classrooms are organized.
They come in in the morning and there's free
play.
And they know the Play-Doh is gonna be on
one table and can have toys and manipulatives
on the rug.
And then there's a signal and a transition
to come together as a group.
And most classrooms will have a little bit
of a group time.
And there's no conversation or discussion
about it because every day, the teacher's
gonna do the same schedule for the child.
And they have internalized it.
We now have a visual schedule in every classroom
of what comes next.
They don't have that little agenda book, which
I use-- 'cause I'm still a Luddite-- or a
little a little PDA that you can go into your
calendar to see what's happening that day.
So for them, it organizes them.
It makes them feel very comfortable.
And on top of things, when they can predict
what's happening next.
They don't tell time by looking at a watch,
but they know after snack there's outdoor
time and after outdoor time, we're gonna have
story and then we're gonna go home.
And the organization of that from the outside
is internalized in them.
And it really gives them that executive functioning
that we're all looking for.
>>Nancy Schulman: So, things like routines
at bedtime and routines in the morning where
there's the most conflict--they don't wanna
go to bed, they don't wanna get dressed to
go to school.
The times when you're rushing out you need
them-- anything that can be put into a routine
is so helpful.
We've had parents tell us that they've taken
this concept of a visual schedule before bedtime
and they'll do a little thing where they'll
actually take a picture that they'll post
on the child's wall of "first, there's bath
time and then teeth brushing and then story,"
and then they'll actually take a picture of
them in their bed.
And instead of having a fight over "come on,
it's time to brush your teeth.
Come on, it's time to take your bath," it's
just there.
OK, this is the thing.
And it works.
And it works because children know exactly
what to expect and it's the same every time.
If you change it up from day to day--.
Children have this incredible sense of knowing
where to zone in on the weak spot on parents.
It's kind of radar-like.
It's like, "Well, if you say the answer is
yes today and the answer is no tomorrow and
it's maybe the next day," they're gonna zone
in right where you really aren't sure of yourself.
And that's where the conflict arises.
So, the more you can put into a routine and
a sense of order for them, the easier it is
for them to respond to something like that.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: Nancy and I, a few years
ago, realized that there were a whole group
of other people involved in the lives of children
that we were not including in the messaging.
And that was the caregivers who are watching
children when they weren't at school, or they
weren't with their parents.
So, we started having meetings and including
them into what the self-help skills we were
using, what the children were learning at
school every day.
And we noticed a change.
So, it's very important whether it's grandparents,
whoever your children are spending time with
to have those conversation about what your
expectations are, what are the rules in your
house?
What do you feel comfortable with in terms
of language with your child?
What is that schedule?
When my daughter went off with her husband
and left her two-year old with us, I got a
very detailed schedule of what his day should
be like.
And I kind of played around it--don't tell
her--but I tried to stick to it to a certain
extent because I knew that would make him
feel more comfortable.
He was in my house and it was unfamiliar to
him in the way his own routine might have
been.
And it was very helpful to know what times
of day certain things that happened.
>>Nancy Schulman: Another thing that's really
important that we are aware of in classrooms
and it's great to have at home is the time
the children need to make a transition from
one activity to the other.
Classrooms use great techniques of you play
a musical instrument, you sing the clean-up
song.
You sing a million different songs to get
them from one activity to the other.
You have little techniques to get children
to say a warning.
Every child needs a warning.
They need a five minute warning.
"In a few minutes, we're gonna start cleaning
up and then come over to meeting, getting
ready for lunch."
Whatever it is.
Because they can't move from one thing to
the other.
They're really intensely involved in play
when they're doing it.
And they really can't move from one to the
other.
So, it's great to give them the warning so
they can get themselves ready.
It doesn't mean they'll pay attention to you,
but they get themselves ready.
I always have this image in my head of a child
sitting in their room and they're playing
with their Lego and they're making this incredibly
imaginative world and they're doing that.
And someone's yelling from the other room,
"Come on in.
It's dinner."
And the child is hearing, "Wa wa wa wa."
And then, the second time.
Again, "Come on.
I called you already.
Dinner."
And they're hearing, "La la la la la."
Something out there.
And the next thing they do is they look and
there's some kind of lunatic adult standing
at their door yelling at them, "I told you
five times to come in."
And 'cause they just didn't have that direct
contact, if you walk in and you get on their
level and you look in their face and you say,
"Andy, it's time to start cleaning up.
We're going to have dinner in a few minutes.
Why don't I help you?"
And then get them ready and transition them
to the next activity.
It enables them to really do that for themselves
and incorporate that kind of ability to move
along in their day.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: The other thing is to really
understand a child's pace.
They're not in the same hurry we are to get
to that next thing.
And they really like to finish what they're
playing with.
They have this unfinished like, thing that
they--.
So, putting whatever they're doing aside or
saying, "We can come back to that," is often
the thing that gets them able to move forward.
Or, planning in your life time so that they
can get dressed by themselves, or time enough
to travel to where you need to get to.
We had one parent at one of our lunch talks
say she was rushing to work.
She had to get her daughter to preschool.
And she was wearing a cardigan sweater.
And she wanted to button it herself.
And you know how many buttons are in a cardigan?
And she looked at her watch and said, "Well,
I can either get to work a little late, get
to preschool a little late, but she's gonna
be able to do this."
And she allowed her child the time to do that.
So, it was very satisfying for the child.
You have to be a little bit aware of their
temperament and their timing and pacing.
>>Nancy Schulman: One of the hardest things
for parents to deal with is discipline because
none of us wanna feel like we're being bossy
with our kids and whatever, but discipline
I think is often misinterpreted as punishment.
And discipline is not punishment.
Discipline is the external order that children
need to have and have repeated in order for
them to internalize a set of rules and a set
of understandings for them to really get what
it is that's really important about behaving.
And unless they've had the external part of
this really defined for them, they can't really
internalize all of it and with its consistency.
I always like to think about like, the job
of the parent is to hold a limit here.
And the job of the child is to press up against
that.
They will press wherever they can press.
And they're gonna keep pressing.
And sometimes it's exhausting 'cause it'll
take 15 times of saying no about the same
thing in order for them to get it.
But if you keep pressing and the expectation
is a moving target, they don't know when to
stop pressing.
So, if you really believe something is important,
if you really want to establish a set of clear
limits in your own household, you have to
just be consistent about it.
I had this--.
My daughter, when she was three, was a child
who needed limit-setting because she was always
pushing the boundaries.
And one day she looked at me and she said,
"Can I have ice cream for breakfast?"
And I said, "No."
And then Day Two came and she said, "Can I
have ice cream for breakfast?"
And I said, "No."
Day Three, Day Four, Day Five.
"Can I have ice cream for breakfast?"
And I'm thinking to myself, "Oh, what's the
big deal.
It's milk."
[laughs] I'm rationalizing why I don't have
to keep saying no to a child.
She not asking for anything so off on then,
the light bulb went on and I said to myself,
"Oh, God.
If I don't say no to her now, this conversation
is going to be really impossible at seven,
thirteen, and seventeen.
We're gonna have so many big issues."
And that's why it's important to think about
the tone and setting those limits at this
age because you can't start doing it when
suddenly, they're 13 and they're asking you
to go to a really big party where there's
going to be nobody there disciplining, or
nobody there supervising.
And so, you have to start from the beginning
and you have to know your child and what they
need and decide what's important to you in
your life 'cause they absolutely need to know
where those limits lie.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: And your children might
be different.
My, our--we didn't have these children together--but
my older--
>>Nancy Schulman: [ laughs and comments inaudibly
]
>>Ellen Birnbaum: child and Nancy's older
child were very self-regulating.
They were the kids who always put their things
away, knew when it was time to get ready for
bed, and brush their teeth.
Our second children were both much more challenging.
And one day, my daughter, who was five years
older than my son, looked at me and she said,
"You know, Charles thinks he's in charge of
us."
And I said--I had my "aha" moment--and I said,
"Oh.
I guess I better set some more limits for
him than I'm already doing because I did not
need to do that the first time around."
So, they may be different.
And you may have one of those marvelous, self-regulating
children, but you have to be the parent to
each of your children in the way.
But children do love rules.
They crave them.
They need them.
And in every classroom at the nursery school,
beginning of the school year, the teachers
brainstorm what are gonna be the rules of
the room that year.
And so, we include it in the book.
We included some of those rules.
>>Nancy Schulman: OK.
This is rules from four-year old children
they made.
Now, if you give a four-year old an unlimited
set of time, the rules will be endless.
You will have 50 rules because they're craving
the rules.
So this is a short list of four-year old rules:
Play nicely with your friends.
Fighting isn't nice.
Running around playing monster is dangerous.
Absolutely no punching, pushing, kicking,
hitting, choking, pinching, pulling hair,
and biting.
Try to figure out a way for everyone to play.
Always tell the truth, even if you don't want
to.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: I love this one: Listen
to your teachers all of the time.
Don't tattle.
Work it out.
Don't laugh at someone's mistake.
Speak in a medium loud voice.
No guns.
Ask for things.
Don't grab.
No teasing anyone.
Don't knock other people's buildings down.
>>Nancy Schulman: I think these are good rules
for all of us to live by.
[Ellen Birnbaum laughs]
I think this works.
But it's very funny.
I was in a classroom last year with a group
of parents and we were walking around.
And on the board, there were the classroom's
list of rules.
So, I said to the children in front of this
group of parents, "What is that?"
They said, "It's our rules."
And I said, "Who wrote it?"
And they said, “We did."
And I said, "What's Number Five?"
And they said, "Hands on your own bodies."
I mean, they all knew it.
They didn't know how to read.
They just knew this was their rules.
Therefore, they could really use them.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: The other thing that comes
up a lot is watching how adults handle children's
frustrations.
I think our first instinct is to swoop in
and fix things for children and smooth the
way for them.
You don't want to see them frustrated and
struggling through.
But the best thing you can do is to stand
back and allow them time to work through problems.
It is the child in the classroom, or in life,
who is going to tenaciously stick with something
until they've accomplished it.
And in order to do that, they have to experience
frustration along the way.
When the building falls down, we're gonna
build it back up.
If things aren't exactly right, what can we
do?
How can we brainstorm?
How can we work together to make that problem
go away?
>>Nancy Schulman: Even at the youngest level,
when your toddler, near 18-month old, who
are the most dangerous things on the planet--you
just have to keep them alive every day.
That should be your goal with a toddler.
'Cause they get into all kinds of stuff and
they don't know any danger.
You watch what happens when they fall down.
The first thing they do is look at your face.
They look at the face of the parent to check
out if they're OK or not.
It's like a titration for pain.
And if you look at them and go like, "Oh,
my God.
What's in my baby?"--they're gonna cry automatically,
whether they hurt themselves or not.
But if they look at you and you say, "OK.
Let me help you up.
Let's go."
You see a whole different mental set for the
child.
And they're looking for you to say, "It's
OK."
And when it is OK to help them be resilient
in that way, they learn that it's OK--.
When you think about what people need in the
workplace when they grow up, they need to
be self-regulated.
They need to be also resilient.
You need to figure out how to solve a problem
when things don't go well.
That's really important.
How to help children move towards that starts
really, really young.
And parents can set the tone for that in every
interaction that you have by doing that over
and over, saying, "It's OK.
We're all OK."
And giving them the OK message all the time.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: Another thing we've been
talking about so much is--you're all in a
cooperative, creative kind of work here--and
when we're watching children in classrooms,
what we want to encourage them to do is to
take some risks and to experience success
sometimes and failure other times and to be
able to tolerate not having things go exactly
right all the time.
And so, we're commenting on their attempts.
"I can see you really took a long time with
that."
Or, "That was really difficult and you really
stayed with it."
And we're encouraging parents to do the same
thing as opposed to praising them for accomplishments.
It's a very, very different kind of message.
>>Nancy Schulman: One of the things that we've
observed, obviously, over the last number
of years is the pace of life for children
and for adults.
I think all of us are very pushed to be moving
in a very fast-paced kind of world that we
live in.
And as a result, children--.
We, as adults, we manage our own paces of
what we need, but children are being pushed
through in terms of over-scheduling and through
paces really, really quickly.
It is not healthy for children, in any way,
to be over-scheduled.
And I think for us, we're feeling really the
pressure that parents are feeling to make
sure that they're getting as early as possible
every advantage into life and every opportunity
to, what we were talking about, playing tennis
at three or being on the soccer team or playing
the violin, or whatever it is.
You have to accomplish so much.
JoAnn Deak, who is a fabulous brain researcher,
says "an overloaded brain does not grow well."
It's a great thing to understand how children
learn.
And children learn by playing and being involved
and having hands-on experiences of all kinds--digging
in the dirt, doing the things that probably,
hopefully you really imagine and remember
from your childhood of the things that really
made you happy and the things that really
gave you satisfactions.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: So we know because we both
are committed and believe that a play-based,
early childhood, nursery school, or school,
is how children learn best.
And they learn best from doing.
Children cannot learn virtually.
They can't watch something and learn it.
They have to manipulate real things in real
time to understand them.
That's how children--.
They learn through all of their senses.
They learn from touching and tasting and moving
their bodies through space.
I mean, in a classroom, if a classroom teacher
wants to teach the children about the color
orange, they're gonna mix yellow and red at
the easel.
They might eat oranges.
They might go on an orange hunt throughout
the classroom and find things that actually
are that color.
They're gonna sing a song about it, 'cause
there's gonna be an auditory learner in the
group.
And they might do it in lots of different
visual ways.
But that's how children learn everything.
And we cannot deprive them of that.
You can't make up the zero to five time.
They can only learn between those years.
That's when the brain is most opened and fluid
and all those synapses are taking place.
The other thing JoAnn Deak talks about is
the need for the time for a child's brain
to process that information.
And that only happens during down time.
You know that time where you think they're
bored 'cause they're not doing anything?
That's when their brains are regrouping, like
a computer.
They're consolidating the information.
They need sleep to be able to do that.
Sleep is when all of that happens.
And quiet time is when all of that happens.
And they can't do it without it.
>>Nancy Schulman: It's interesting.
We see definitely the impact of what happens
when children have too much going on in their
lives in the classroom.
When they have too much too soon, or too many
things that go on, you see children who lack
focus, who talk about being bored.
It's very interesting that boredom doesn't
mean that at all.
They need a lot of direction.
They're not very creative because they can't
really think for themselves because they've
gone from one structured activity to the other.
And everybody's telling them what to do--line
up here, do this, let's kick the ball, let's
do this.
And they can't really think for themselves
about the kinds of things that creativity
really comes from.
And they often say--.
It's very sad to see a three- or four-year
old in a classroom looking around a wonderful
classroom with a lot of wonderful things and
great activities going on saying, "I don't
know what to do."
They can't initiate play for themselves.
They can't really think for themselves.
And they can't really make choices because
the choices keep being made for them.
And so, they haven't practiced the skill of
making a choice and making a decision and
then finding they don't really like that or
they do really like that.
And those are the things that really push
children to really be creative thinkers and
problem solvers.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: You know, in the book, when
we went to research toys because our kids
were pretty old by the time we wrote the book,
and we went into a toy store.
And there was actually a video on digging,
as opposed to like, going to the park and
taking a shovel and digging.
A child would be actually--.
The idea of a child sitting on a sofa at home
watching somebody dig?
It was horrifying.
>>Nancy Schulman: It was horrifying.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: It was a horrifying moment.
But one day, one of the teachers was showing--trying
to show--a film on the VCR and it was broken.
And we had this old-fashioned TV at school
with VCR.
>>Nancy Schulman: VHS.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: VHS.
And Nancy said, "I'm gonna replace it."
And what?
What happened?
>>Nancy Schulman: I went to every store on
86th Street to replace this thing to watch
the end of this stupid video tape.
And I walked into the store--
>>Ellen Birnbaum: They were laughing.
>>Nancy Schulman: and it must have been the
moment in time when there were no more TV
sets and everything was a flat screen.
And I walked in and I looked at them.
I said, "I need a TV with like a--."
And they looked at me like I landed from another
planet.
And I said, "No, no.
I really need--.
It comes in a box and it's kinda square.
You may have seen them.
I'm sure you might have one in the back corner
of a dusty store room."
They actually found me the last TV on the
planet, which I brought back to the classroom,
told the children the story.
And I left the box in the room with this.
And the guessing game that just happens around
"what's in the box?"
Now of course, we took the TV out of the box.
And you know what the end of the story is.
They played for the rest of the day with the
box because the box was so much more interesting
than anything else that you can imagine playing
with.
But I think that a great reminder in looking
at toys for children is that a toy should
be 90 percent kid, ten percent toy.
If it has a battery, it's not a good toy.
If you can't play with it in more than three
ways, it's not a good toy.
You need to have something that you can play
with in many, many different ways and that
the child can determine how the play needs
to go, as opposed to the toy determining how
the play needs to go.
[Ellen Birnbaum clears throat]
>>Ellen Birnbaum: I was gonna say that one
of the best class trips that our children
go on each year is they go to Central Park
and they dig for worms in the Spring.
You can't imagine the joy of finding your
first worm and putting it into a jar.
Then we have to tell the parents to pretend
they're having a good time, too.
But they do because they're children are.
But there's so much about nature that is important
for children.
And if you live in New York City, you still
have lots of access to parks and playgrounds
and going along the waterways and talking
with your children and experiencing nature
with your children.
And it is a very important part of life.
They need to be connected to this planet,
to this world that we live in.
And there's nothing like a first-hand experience
with real things.
It's also a great way to talk about death
with children.
It fits into the cycle of life.
You know, this plant is green and this plant
is brown.
What's the difference?
But there's all of this.
And the Academy of Pediatrics, the American
Academy of Pediatrics, really stresses the
importance of outdoor play and moving their
bodies as well.
You get that opportunity, too.
>>Nancy Schulman: The other thing that the
American Academy of Pediatrics says, has come
out recently with the position on is no TV,
video, or computers for children under the
age of two.
And it is almost--.
It is the most natural thing in the world
for a child to pick up their parent's technology
and just, they just do it.
And they just obviously can do it, but there's
nothing in it that they can really learn that
they really need at that point in time in
their lives.
And I think that the National Association
of Education for Young Children has come out
with a position paper on technology and media
with children from birth to age eight.
And it needs to be limited.
It can be used in very effective ways, but
it really needs to be limited.
And the time spent using it needs to be limited.
And it's very hard for parents, and for children,
who find it very seductive to be working on
computers and to be doing games with children
on computers.
They're so into it, but children really learn
only by doing and being involved in interactive,
three-dimensional real things.
And they must have time for play.
And computers absolutely have a role in their
life and will continue to.
But it must be on a limited kind of basis.
And children need time to do things like every
day stuff--doing the laundry with you, going
shopping at the supermarket, walking down
the street.
In terms of technology--I just wanna mention
one other thing-- it also means that parents
have to turn off, too.
We asked parents a couple of years ago to
say, "If you can think about how many minutes--'cause
it really comes down to minutes--in a day
that you spend with your child that's undivided
time when you're not distracted by looking
at something else, texting on something else,
working on the computer, making dinner, reading
a book, reading the newspaper, looking through
your mail, whatever it is, checking email
constantly, whatever that time is, is time
that children do not understand you're focused
on them."
Children only think you're focused on them
when you're actually making eye contact with
them--when you're on their level and looking
at them.
If you're doing this and you're using your
thumbs and you're doing this and talking to
them at the same time, they do not know that
you are actually listening.
They need you to--.
You should tell the story about the car.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: Well, I was getting dressed
for work one morning and there was a wonderful
program on NPR about this couple, who were
going on trip with their children.
And the mom left her device, her cell phone,
Blackberry, whatever, in the trunk of the
car.
And she was forced to have this interaction
with her children.
So they were playing games and they were looking
for punch buggies along the highway.
And then she realized that it was such a wonderful
opportunity to actually converse and play
with her kids.
It was more relaxed.
She wasn't distracted.
So, she and her husband, after that experience,
took turns leaving--.
You know, because it's very irresistible.
If you have it, you're gonna use it.
So, putting it away is the only way to control
that.
But I was thinking we had a language specialist
also in our last conference and talked about
how the technology is affecting language acquisition
of children who came from homes where the
parents were at a certain level of education,
always had a distinct advantage of acquiring
language and vocabulary at a much more rapid
rate than people who are less well-educated
because we naturally go into a narration of
the world.
From the time our babies are born, we're talking
about them and what we're doing.
But that has decreased with all the distraction
of devices.
And there is a risk for a child not to hear
the language, not to be interacting.
When they're two, you're supposed to have
two back and forth conversation--.
You know, a child should be able to answer
back two times, a three-year old three times,
four-year old.
Back and forth conversation should be at a
flow.
But a child's not gonna be able to do that
if they're not made eye contact with and they're
not being talked to.
So, that's a big risk.
And what Nancy's saying is that you have to
put together some kind of diet for yourself
with the technology, both for the child and
for the parent.
>>Nancy Schulman: And you have to give permission
to yourself to play because children really
wanna do that.
So, being outdoors, running, climbing, jumping,
throwing, drawing, pretending, reading, telling
stories.
They love to hear stories about you when you
were a child, too.
Playing games, solving puzzles--those are
the ways in which interacting with children
on their level at this age is the most wonderful
kinds of interactions that you can have.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: One of my favorite memories
of playing with my kids is creating tents
in my house.
You know, you take the big blanket and you
have a flashlight and you put it over the
chairs.
I think every child-- you can remember doing
this when you were a child.
It was just a lot of fun.
>>Nancy Schulman: So, one of the things that
we did when we wrote this book--.
We were talking before we wrote the book.
We were talking about why it is that certain
children seem so comfortable in their own
skin and why they come to school feeling like,
really able and capable and confident in all
those ways.
And we said, "No one reads anymore.
Let's see if we can figure out what are the
commonalities that are in the lives of those
children that make them feel so good in their
own skin."
So we came up with a page of bullet points
of all the things that we could discover about
these children and their families.
And we said, "All right.
We can do this on one page."
Which we did.
And we put together bullet points that were
on one page to give to parents.
And then we wrote 352 more pages about all
of those things and a few more things, too.
[chuckling] But we thought we'd just close
with sharing with you some of the things that
really parents--.
Parenting is definitely not a sprint.
It's a marathon.
And there's an awful lot of things that you
can do a lot of mistakes in your life.
But if you can incorporate as much of this
stuff into your lives with your children,
it makes all the difference in the world.
So, some of those are establishing clear routines,
encouraging age appropriate self-help skills,
sharing family meals whenever you can, allowing
children to experience frustration and cope
with disappointment.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: Helping children problem
solve and be resilient, teaching respect for
others, the difference between right and wrong
and the importance for taking responsibility
for actions, insisting on basic manners, especially
saying "please" and "thank you," thinking
about the family as a team and understanding
that all of a child's developing skills are
important, not just their academic skills,
setting aside unstructured family time.
>>Nancy Schulman: Giving children time and
space to play, limiting after-school activities,
understand that though school is important,
the most important influence in children is
home.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: I think we end with the
two most important things that, as a parent,
if you do nothing else, you need to do these
two things.
You need to love them unconditionally.
Love the child that you have, not the child
that you wanted to have.
>>Nancy Schulman: And also to set limits.
There's a lot of things that you can make
mistakes in, but when you do this and you
set limits and love your child unconditionally
and know who they are, they grow up as healthy,
secure children.
If you do one and not the other, it's not
enough.
You have to do both those things.
Anything else of these other things that you
can layer into your life as parents makes
all the difference in the world.
It also means to have fun, to have a sense
of humor, and to know that there's no such
thing as a perfect parent.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: And if the days seem endless,
the years fly by.
And the one thing you can't get back is that
time.
So, worry less and enjoy it more.
>>Nancy Schulman: Thank you and we would love
to hear some questions from you.
[applause]
So what are some of the things you guys struggle
with?
Yeah?
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #1: In my case I
have two things that are regarding the attitude
of my two and a half year old.
I'm worried about patience.
>>Nancy Schulman: Yours or your child's?
[laughter]
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #1: A little bit
of both.
Not of both, but his.
He actually thinks patience is the rainbow
circle on the iPad.
He calls that patience.
And so, you read the M&M story--the famous
M&M story--and I'm just wondering, are there
ways that parents can teach that in this on-demand
world?
We'll listen to the radio and he's like, "Play
Lady Gaga again."
And I'm like, "I can't.
It's on the radio."
But they just assume, in this on-demand world
that can happen.
So I'm just curious kind of in this digital
world, how do we teach about patience?
And the other one is entitlement, especially
for these New York kids.
They have nannies.
They are going to preschool and have somebody
hovering over them all the time.
I try to go out of my way to try to ignore
them sometimes.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: That's great.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #1: It's because
I am concerned--.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: Good for you.
I think the fact that you're thinking about
it at all is going to make a difference.
I think we set an example in terms of patience,
too.
I think if we're so fast-paced and New Yorkers
talk so fast.
It's so hard to keep up sometimes for children.
So, I think just the fact that you're slowing
down and you're setting a different pace will
help them.
>>Nancy Schulman: It's also, I think, nature
has a really great place.
You know what?
Plant a seed.
I was just thinking about like, as an opportunity
for learning.
You plant a seed.
The seed doesn't come up the next day.
You have to water it.
You have to check it.
You have to keep going back and checking it.
Having things that are not obviously instant
gratification in their lives, to give as many
examples of those things that are possible.
I think it' a hard thing to fight against.
It's great that you're thinking about it.
I think in terms of the caregiver piece of
this, one of the things that we started doing
a number of years ago, was really including
caregivers in our conversations at school
because when you think about it--.
I think when you have someone who is helping
out, taking care of your child, you're paying
them to do something that's for your child.
And I think that what is really important
is that they understand and include as many
conversations as you can have with your caregiver
about your expectations.
And that it's OK for them to struggle getting
dressed by themselves and that it's OK for
them to figure something else out by themselves.
I think that doesn't happen naturally unless
you set the tone for that and explain that's
really important.
And we've started to do that with caregivers
because they're such an important part of
a child's life that you wanna make sure that
that consistency of expectation is there for
everybody who's interacting with your child.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: I wanted to speak to your
point about entitlement because I think if
you're fortunate enough to have the ability
to send your children to these quality programs
and you're living your life in that way, you've
set an example for your children in the way
you give back and allowing them to participate
with you.
We just had Thanksgiving, so at the nursery
school, we have a bake sale, but part of the
bake sale was to bake things for--.
Goddard Riverside has Feeds the Homeless,
so the children from some of the classes bake
baked goods for Goddard and then we have them
make cards for it.
You can do that with your children in whatever
way that you can teach them that part of being
a responsible person is to give back and to
help take care.
And that could start in the home.
Just having them help you take care of things
in the house and making them feel like they
have some responsibility back to the family
team that we were talking about.
>>Nancy Schulman: I think doing things like
helping make the salad, doing things where
it's really like doing something that helps
everybody else--cleaning up your toys, doing
that thing.
There's a great story that Wendy Mogel tells
also.
It's about buying things for your kids.
I think as working parents, we overly worry
about the guilt stuff.
Guilt is such a wasted emotion.
And it really interferes with good common
sense.
But in terms of thinking about things like
what we buy for our kids, in terms of that,
she tells a great story about a little boy
who loved his Matchbox car.
And everywhere he went, this Matchbox car
came.
So his father went out and bought a whole
case of Matchbox cars for him because, of
course, more is better.
And the child stopped playing with the cars
entirely.
And the father said to the child, "Why don't
you play?
I thought you loved your Matchbox cars.
Why don't you play with them anymore?"
And he said, "I just don't know how to love
this many cars."
And it's such a poignant story because it
just is so easy to slip into that feeling
of "it's coming from a good place and I want
to do more for my child," but in doing that,
you're also doing something that undermines
the value of what they have.
If something that it breaks that's replaced
right away, it's undermining that value.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #2: I was just wondering
if you had any thoughts on the difference
between a child that goes to a day care and
a child that stays with a stay-at-home mom.
And what type of daycares actually do as good
of a job or better?
>>Ellen Birnbaum: Well, I have a grandchild
at a very high-quality daycare.
His experience is extraordinary and now, the
nine-month old is there.
It depends on the program.
I see a very healthy, well-developed child
because the child's needs are being met over
the course of this long day.
The pace of the learning and the pace of his
day at each and every age and stage was very
appropriate.
And I watch that my daughter and my son-in-law
were focused on their children when they were
home.
And so, there was a very nice balance.
So these children went off and they understood
what it means to be part of a group and could
accommodate.
So, I think you have to just look for a program
that you feel comfortable with that has trained
teachers and is going to be very good at communicating
with you.
Because if you have your child in school from
8:30 to 4:30, or whatever your needs are,
you're gonna need a lot of communication from
that school.
And the school should want a lot of communication
from you.
So that's a really important thing to ask.
>>Nancy Schulman: I think it's a hard decision
because there's no right and wrong with this,
either.
And you have to do what you think is most
appropriate for your life and your family,
too.
I would say that the one thing about putting
your child in daycare or keeping your child
at home is that they do have, at least starting
around age two, some group experiences with
other children.
So, between two and three, they become social
for the first time.
They're not parallel playing, but they’re
really playing with each other.
And I think children really get a tremendous
amount from spending time with other children.
You don't really learn to share [chuckles]
unless that truck is going to be battled over.
And you need to have those experiences to
figure out what you need to do to negotiate
your way in the world.
But there's not a right or wrong decision
about--.
I mean, you can spend time at home and really
not be doing some high-quality things.
And a daycare can go from being something
really incredibly high-quality to also being
not.
I would look at the track record of the teachers
there.
I would look at their qualifications and the
turnover rate at any daycare and talk to parents
whose children go there to see about their
satisfaction with it.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #3: So, my 15-month
old son is starting to make projectiles out
of an increasing number of things--
[laughter]
including food and books and you know, he
just likes to see things go--
>>Nancy Schulman: It's fun.
It's fun.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #3: and fly through
the air.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: Where are they gonna land?
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #3: Right.
So, it's obviously difficult for him to understand
what is OK to throw and what is not.
And we're starting to develop tactics for
disciplines.
So, at what age do you think kids can understand
"no" and at what ages are different forms
of disciplines effective and appropriate?
>>Nancy Schulman: Well, he can understand
the difference right now of "yes" and "no."
And I think it's a hard thing 'cause you don't
want him to not throw things, but you don't
want him to throw that thing then.
So, I think one of the things about 15-month
olds that are wonderful is that they're easy
to distract.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #3: Yeah.
>>Nancy Schulman: I mean, he's looking for
your reaction.
There's no question that you know, you throw
something and you get a reaction.
And that's the fun part of doing that.
But it's really easy to say, "OK.
Let's go in the other room and throw socks
at the bed."
You can turn it so that you can make it an
appropriate activity as opposed to saying
"no."
And then, just turn it a little bit, too.
But when you're picking up something to throw
that's going to break something or hurt someone,
there's just this simple thing is "no."
You take it away.
You change the activity.
Remove him from the room.
And you say "no."
And you say it very clearly and very firmly.
And you change the look on your face.
It's not like, "No, sweetie.
We don't throw things."
That doesn't get anybody anywhere.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #3: Right.
>>Nancy Schulman: You have to change the look
on your face.
You have to change tone quality.
And you say "no" and you take it away.
And then you can't expect them to be happy
because they're going to be really mad at
you.
And when they're about three, they'll tell
you they hate you because you've done it.
And they don't mean that, but they mean it
in the moment.
But you have to be clear.
He can understand it right now to do that.
But distraction is the first round and then
a clear "no," removing the object, changing
the activity.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #3: So, at what age
do you certain time-outs and words--?
>>Nancy Schulman: The rule of thumb with time-outs
is that this is a chance to take the temperature
down, change the activity.
I don't think until three, probably, that's
very effective because they won't stay.
[laughs]
They just won't.
You can't get them to.
You can't make them.
And usually the rule of thumb is time-out
is no more than the age of the child.
So, you would never have a time-out more than
two minutes or three minutes for anything.
And sometimes, it just means you have to stop
the activity and move it elsewhere, or just
to say--.
In school, we wouldn’t call it a time-out,
but we would call it just like, "We need to
take a break.
We need to just take some big deep breaths.
Let's just do something else."
Sometimes, it's just changing your like, -- Their
engines are running fast.
You want to turn the engine down a little
bit.
And even describing it to them as an engine--for
little boys, that's a great technique, too.
Let's see if we can turn it down.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: The other thing is when
they're there, you need to be here.
You need to really keep your tone down.
And we all talk too much at children when
they're like that.
That's the other major no-no.
So, moving them, we need time to think, calm
down.
It helps.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #3: Thank you.
>>Nancy Schulman: Hope he didn't break anything.
[laughter]
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #4: I have a question.
It's probably my son's fault that your son
throws things 'cause they play together.
>>Nancy Schulman: Oh, let's blame it on each
other.
It's a great technique.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: Setting a bad example, yeah.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #4: I have a question
about TV watching.
I'm gonna bring it up.
I'm totally guilty.
My two-year old loves TV, loves movies.
And for me, it's actually a saving grace in
the day.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: Of course.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #4: I need that 30
minutes where he can watch a TV show.
And I'm trying to be careful about selecting
what he's watching and making sure that it's
age appropriate.
But I would say he's probably watching 30
minutes, sometimes up to an hour a day.
And I know, I don't know.
I guess I'm wondering how bad that is and
am I really the only one that's doing this
'cause it feels like--.
I can't imagine--.
>>Nancy Schulman: If anyone denies that they're
doing that, they're lying.
[laughter]
>>Ellen Birnbaum: Guess what.
We both did that, too.
I mean, you know what?
There's sometimes you just need the time and
there's nothing like it.
I think you have to think about what they're
watching and when they're watching.
One thing we did learn is before bedtime is
a really bad thing to do because the images,
the flickering, gets the brain all--.
They look calm, but it's getting them all
like, agitated.
So, one of the things we discovered was doing
it earlier in the day if you need that break
time.
This would probably be better.
And then the what.
>>Nancy Schulman: Yeah.
I think you're being thoughtful about what's
age appropriate.
It's always so horrifying when we have children
come to school, and especially when you have
older siblings it's really hard to control,
but one will tell us they'll have seen something
that you think like, "What could they be thinking?
They let this child--," if you think about
the imagery on some of these things.
The other thing to add, so I think a half
an hour or a little more, if you have to use
it from time to time, it is sometimes a parent's
life saver.
The other thing to be aware of is that, at
times, you putting TV--.
I know I use TV in the background.
My husband said to me just the other day,
"How can you do three things when the TV's
on?"
I said, "'Cause I'm not really watching it.
It's just like background noise."
And what happens is, is if you put on the
news or some other thing and you have a child
in the room, they're not filtering it out.
They're watching it and they're not understanding
it.
So, if there's like--.
There's horrible things on the news that you
gonna see.
There's fires and earthquakes and horrible
things happening in the news.
They don't filter that out and they also don't
know it's not happening near them or right
now or whether they're in danger.
And they're very upsetting images.
And it's important to think about that aspect
of your own TV.
And monitoring your own TV watching as a role
model for your children's TV watching, too.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: Do you have a son?
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #4: I do.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: I hate to be sexist, but--
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #4: Yeah.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: but my grandson watches
these videos called Mighty Machines and it's
fabulous because it's about real things.
So, one goes into a salt mine and there's
farm equipment and you follow them.
And they talk and it's fabulous.
So I think there's a learning component in
some way and there's something that's very
satisfying about watching things happening
that are very real.
Like, there's a logging machine.
>>Nancy Schulman: And it's also not happening
fast.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: No, it's very slow.
You've seen it.
>>Nancy Schulman: It's not fast-paced.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: It's very slow-paced, which
is quite nice.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #4: Thanks.
That's helpful.
Thanks.
>>Nancy Schulman: And hopefully you don't
feel really guilty, too.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: Don't feel guilty.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #5: Hi.
My son, my first son, is a two-year old and
two weeks.
And he's a very good boy.
He's very independent.
He's very caring and sensitive.
And usually, when he accidentally hit us or
hit something, I make the face that I was
hurt.
Well, not make face when I'm hurt--when I'm
really hurt or something.
He will just immediately come to hug me, to
make me feel better.
And he would also hug his animals.
But one question that I have right now is
I wonder at what--.
But there was one little issues that when
in the morning sometimes, when I need a little
bit extra sleep, he just wouldn't give me.
He really wants me to get up and play with
him.
>>Nancy Schulman: Sure.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #5: And yeah.
I know that that's the thing that I should
not really force him to accept that, but a
couple of months back, he was better when
we told him that Mama needs a little sleep,
he would just go with Papa.
But now, he's getting more attached to me
maybe.
So he wants me to get up.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: Well, you're pregnant.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #5: Yeah, that's
also why I do need more sleep sometimes.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: Sure.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #5: I just wonder
at what point is he gonna be more understanding
about other people's needs.
He's only two.
I understand he wouldn't be able to understand
it so much right now, but how to tell him
little by little so that he can let me get
more time.
Because we also need to prepare for the next
one.
>>Nancy Schulman: I think the one thing you
should be aware of is that your two-year old
being that sensitive and empathetic at this
age is unusual.
I mean, you already have a very caring and
empathetic child.
I think he's probably feeling a little more
needy of you because he's aware of something
else that's happening in his life shortly.
[chuckles]
>>Ellen Birnbaum: He can't fit into your lap
in the same way.
Just beginning with then, what Nancy's saying,
is they're incredibly egocentric at that period
of their lives.
They are the center of the universe for them.
It takes really, all these years between two
and five and six for them to really understand
and become that empathetic and understanding
kind of person.
So, you have to be a little patient with him.
>>Nancy Schulman: And the truth is, after
the baby is born, he's gonna need--.
You're gonna need more sleep and he's gonna
need more of you, too.
So, if you can carve out some special alone
time with him, that's gonna ward off a little
bit of that, too.
But if he has some favorite toys or there's
something that can keep him busy and you can
be sleeping, but have some toys in the bed
with you and doing that, maybe if he can play
a little bit quietly, you might get a little
more time, but probably not too much.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #5: Yeah.
I feel like he wants us to play together with
him.
>>Nancy Schulman: Yeah.
But I mean, I think you can say, "This is
quiet time and you can play these games near
us, but we need to do that."
But it's a little young for them to be understanding
that Mommy needs her sleep.
Yeah.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #5: Yeah.
I sometimes try to tell him that you see when
you need to sleep or when you are tired, we
wouldn't force you to do anything.
>>Nancy Schulman: Developmentally, he's not
quite there.
With children, until they're at least five,
really don't really put themselves in somebody
else's shoes.
Just as a psychological understanding of that,
they're not really able to do that.
You know, "This is what I need."
They know what they need, but they're really
not able to make that switch quite yet.
So developmentally, they're not really there
yet.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #5: Will it still
be useful to find the opportunity to tell
him?
>>Nancy Schulman: You can tell him and you
can talk to him about it, but he's only going
to understand it on a very limited basis.
He's definitely looking for more from you.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #5: So, basically
I just have to find a balance.
>>Nancy Schulman: Exactly.
And that's the secret of any kind of parenting
issues is finding that balance that works
for you, works for him, trying to figure that
out.
That's the hard part.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #5: I'll just make
myself more time.
[laughter]
>>Nancy Schulman: I think that's gonna be
your life for a while, I'm afraid to say.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: Yeah, just kind of tough
it out.
[laughter]
>>Nancy Schulman: It does get better eventually.
>>Female Announcer: So that's all we have
time for.
Thank you so much for coming.
>>Nancy Schulman: Thank you.
Thank you.
>>Ellen Birnbaum: Thank you for having us.
Thanks.
[applause]